So
welcome everyone. Hello, my name is Jonine Horton. My pronouns are she and her. We're
so glad you're all here with us tonight and all of you online too as well. We'll start
off with a few announcements. We would like to work together as a table team to build
a wheelchair ramp for someone in need this fall. And so we're in touch with an organization
that we can partner with, but we need to get an idea of who may want to help us and be
interested in participating. So the QR code is up there and if you will just fill out
the form and let us know if you're interested in building wheelchair ramps. Okay, big date
here, June 14, 2025, Dallas. Okay, and we have a booth in the Pride Festival and we
need volunteers to represent the table. So again, right there, sign up at the QR code.
Okay, Summerama. Summerama Kids event is happening on Saturday, June the 28th. It's here in the
gem of Sachse First and it will be a full day experience for the kids going into kindergarten
all the way through sixth grade with water activities, Bible study, crafts, food, and
fun. So sign up at the QR code. All right, Accessibility Bucket. One of the things that
I love about this congregation is that it's very thoughtful. It's one of the key things
about the vision here. And so if you are anxious about being in a church setting or a part
of the disability community or just feeling fidgety today, we have an Accessibility Bucket
available to you over at the table to my left. Okay, there are noise-canceling headphones,
fidgets, and coloring sheets. We just ask that you return them to the bucket at the
end of the service. All right, we light these candles as a sign of the presence of Christ
among us, fully divine and fully human. And now we exit the kingdom of noise, hurry, and
productivity. Now we enter the kingdom, the community of silence and stillness and simplicity.
A sacred space, a place for prayer, worship, and adoration. A place to behold Christ, revelation
of God, heartbeat of creation. So allow the unforced rhythms of grace to find you, to
embrace you, to mend your heart, and may we all come home to worship.
Thanks, Johnnie. Would you guys stand with us? We're going to get started with the way
tonight. We're so thankful to be worshiping together in this space, and we just invite you
and everything that you carry into this worship time. Would we hold it with open
hands before a God who's for us, who loves us, and sees us, and is walking this path with us.
Through every battle, through every heartbreak, through every circumstance,
I believe that you are my fortress, you are my portion, you are my hiding place.
I believe you are the way, the truth, the light. I believe you are the way, the truth, the light.
I believe through every promise, through every promise, through every breath I take,
I believe that you are providing, you are protecting, you are the one I love.
I believe you are the way, the truth, the light. I believe you are the way, the truth, the light.
And I'm set on you, and you meet me here today, the mercies that are new.
All my fears and doubts, they can all come true, because they can't stay long when I'm here with you.
It's a new horizon, and I'm set on you, and you meet me here today, the mercies that are new.
All my fears and doubts, they can all come true, because they can't stay long when I believe you are the way,
the truth, the light. I believe you are the way, the truth, the light. I believe you are the way, the truth, the light.
I believe you are the way, the truth, the light. I believe you are the way, the truth, the light.
It's a new horizon, and I'm set on you, and you meet me here today, the mercies that are new.
And all my fears and doubts, they can all come true, because they can't stay long when I'm here with you.
Alright kids, you guys are dismissed to go to your classes. Thank you teachers for loving on them tonight.
And we just invite each one of you to speak out loud when we get to that portion of the prayer,
anything that you're carrying into this space, whether it's relational, someone's on your heart,
or a situation, you can just speak that out, and then we'll close out the prayer together,
and the parts in red, we'll read aloud as well.
I'm so sorry.
Jesus, for this city of Saxie, Texas, and for every city and community and all who live in them,
we pray to you. For the good earth that you have given us, and the wisdom and the will to conserve
it, we pray to you. For the old and the sick, the widow and the orphan, for the injured and the
suffering, we pray to you. For the poor and the oppressed, the unemployed and destitute, for
prisoners and captives, and all who remember and care for them, we pray to you. For those experiencing
loss, loneliness, and disconnection, and for those struggling with mental and emotional health,
we pray to you. Lord, we know that you love us, and that you hear us, so we lift these names and
situations up to you.
Amen.
For the names and the moments that we have spoken aloud, and for those that we have kept in our
hearts, we pray to you that they may have life and light, healing and hope, peace, and a deep sense of
your presence. Amen.
You broke my chains of sin and shame, and you covered me with grace.
You meant my life, your holy fire, you covered me with grace.
You are the heaven reaches out to save, I am set free, oh, oh, oh, oh, I am set free, oh, oh, oh, oh,
oh, oh, oh, it is for freedom that I am set free.
One, two, three.
You broke my chains of sin and shame, and you covered me with grace.
You meant my life, your holy fire, you covered me with grace.
You are the heaven reaches out to save, I am set free, oh, oh, oh, oh, I am set free, oh, oh, oh, oh,
it is for freedom that I am set free, I am set free, oh, oh, oh, oh, I am set free, oh, oh, oh, oh,
it is for freedom that I am set free.
And yes, Lord, we are grateful for your grace and for your love.
Yes, Lord, we are grateful for your grace and for your love.
You are the heaven reaches out to save, I am set free, oh, oh, oh, oh, I am set free, oh, oh, oh, oh, it is for freedom that I am set free.
Sing that again.
I am set free, oh, oh, oh, oh, I am set free, oh, oh, oh, oh, it is for freedom that I am set free.
And I'm no longer a slave to fear, no, I am a child of God.
I'm no longer a slave to fear, cause I am a child of God.
You unravel me with a melody, you surround me with a song of deliverance from my enemies till all my fears are gone.
And I'm no longer a slave to fear, no, I am a child of God.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
You split the sea so I could walk right through.
My fears are drowned in perfect love.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
You rescued me so I could stand and sing.
I am a child of God.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
You split the sea so I could walk right through.
My fears are drowned in perfect love.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
You rescued me so I could stand and sing.
I am a child of God.
And I'm no longer a slave to sin.
No, I am a child of God.
I'm no longer a slave to fear.
God, we recognize that each one of us have our own fears,
the things that hold us back, the insecurities that we can't
quite overcome, the things that we're unsure about in our
future, maybe even our present.
And God, I'm so prone to grasp for control.
But tonight, God, help us to open our hands and to trust a
God who calls us his child, who says we are your beloved,
your good creation, your prized possession,
the sheep that you run after and bring back home,
the prodigal that you call back and celebrate.
Would we trust the God who loves us, who knows us,
who created us?
And would we keep our eyes on you,
the author of our faith and our life?
Would all the other distractions and fears and the things that
are out of our control, God, would they melt away in the
presence of your love?
Would they take second place to you and your voice and what it
says about us and our life?
Would your words be the loudest in our heads and in our hearts
tonight?
In Jesus' name, amen.
Thank you, guys, for worshiping with us.
If you can turn to someone beside you and say,
the peace of Christ be with you.
We'll move on.
Well, grace and peace.
Welcome.
Welcome to the table.
So, so good to be with you all.
And my name is Brett.
And I'm here to welcome you all.
So it's a privilege to be here, and I'm very excited to be here.
And I'm really excited to hear your pronouns, he, him.
And yeah, just a joy, joy to welcome you.
And as always, that includes those join us online.
Y'all are not forgotten.
And yeah, it's just really, really good to be with you tonight.
So we are, we're in a series right now titled enchanted.
Reclaiming sacred ground.
In a disenchanted world.
The secular, a critique of kind of the way a secular world,
which really has kind of done its best.
It's sort of a grand experiment in ways that we're living through,
sort of a political, social, philosophical,
and in ways religious kind of experiment where it's like,
okay, so what if we like sort of let go of the idea,
you know, of God, religion, you know,
all the kind of grand stories that have kind of guided humans
for, you know, like thousands of years.
Like what if we sort of put all that to the side,
and at least in the kind of public sphere, you know,
and kind of relegate that to just the private.
Kind of like, hey, if you want to do something with Jesus,
you know, quietly, okay, you do that.
But in terms of any sort of public social way,
like, oh, let's marginalize all that.
And kind of see how that goes.
Actually, next week we'll talk about politics.
And really it was done largely for political purposes.
So we'll kind of work through the messiness of like
what all that means in our kind of world today.
But at any rate, it's, you know, the trick is,
honestly, I would say if there's any upside
to this sort of grand experiment,
it's honestly in the realm of politics
and like some of the changes that motivate it were there.
I would say the downside is everything else.
I mean, everything the secular touches,
it just is like ruined, ruined.
Like, because in essence, if you think of it,
the reason it's not, I don't think it's,
no one's like bad intentions or something.
It's more like, like last week, for example,
we talked about creation, right?
As opposed to nature, sort of a mechanized,
very sort of godless view.
But like, instead of creation, right,
it's sort of like, oh, the whole world,
as it was at Gerard Manley Hopkins,
the world's charged with the grandeur of God.
You know, spirit infusing all things.
So when you're looking at something,
it's not just like, oh, a lifeless thing.
It's, you know, it's somehow,
there's something divine about it.
You know, even human beings have the image of God.
So that's like a good example where
it's sort of, as you can see,
the kind of zest you get from that.
You know what I mean?
It's sort of like a jolt of like liveliness.
And this is what sort of makes a lot of life worth living,
you know, is like beauty, the arts.
I mean, that's another thing.
I don't know if we'll get to it in this series,
but the arts, womp,
are just drained, right?
Because there's something sort of mirroring about,
like we're participating in the divine as we create,
you know, as we sing and music,
and it's just, you can see where there's sort of a liveliness there,
and it's like, yeah!
But you try to secularize that.
It just drains the life out of it.
It's like, I don't know, what is art?
Is it just pretty things?
Or maybe it's political!
It's political!
You know, and all of a sudden,
that gets kind of its own weirdness,
like kind of cool, but then kind of weird
to just instrumentalize your art.
You know, so that's just a few examples.
Again and again, it's just,
everything it touches, the secular touches,
it just sort of, big womp.
So that's kind of the critique,
really what we're doing in this series,
just going through example after example
of like, this isn't so good.
This isn't so great.
And so, and then trying to kind of say,
okay, well how does Christian faith,
how does Christ kind of address that
and re-infuse it so that we can bring
a kind of liveliness back to our own lives
and, you know, really the world.
So anyway, that's kind of what we're doing in this series.
So the title of the message this week,
it's really all about community.
So it's titled,
Escaping Isolation, Recovering the Communal.
So you can probably see a little bit
of where I'm going, right?
Again, where the secular,
what happens when you apply that
at the communal level,
or what it means for society and relationships.
Again, you get this kind of draining.
So we'll talk some about that draining
and then how to re-infuse it.
So our key scripture is John 15, 12 through 13,
where Jesus said this,
I love this verse, or these two verses.
My command is this.
Love each other as I have loved you.
And greater love has no one than this
to lay down one's life for one's friends.
I went to really a church for many years.
It was extremely formative for me,
like pretty much all my 20s,
half my 30s I was there,
and even 30s part I was on staff at that church.
And they had, like just far and away
the highest value at this church
was relationships and community.
It was just like an obsession almost.
You know, like this is the thing.
We love the term, we put the word real before it,
so it's like all about real relationships.
And by real, the idea was kind of authentic, right?
Not surface level, not fake,
but kind of a real, like real relationships.
And of course by relationship
it was referring a little bit more to friendship.
We did talk a lot about marriage in that community,
but when we use at least that phrase, real relationships,
it really was something more than that.
It was like friendships and the communal element.
And I was really intrigued,
like I wasn't born and raised in that church,
so I came to it right in my,
I mean I was still young, I was like 19 or so
when I first went there,
but still I saw it a little bit
with an outsider's kind of view,
and I was really intrigued by this like value
and it's almost an obsession.
I mean, you know, in a kind of good way though,
like every other sermon was about this,
like I've heard it said every preacher really has one message
and they're just saying it like a thousand different ways.
You know, that might be overly reductionistic,
where, I don't know, maybe we have like,
I probably have like five to seven themes,
but I'm just hitting those things, you know,
I'm just like doing it at different angles.
And that was this kind of church, you know,
like had that kind of like,
this is the passion, this is the driving force, you know.
And I think a lot of the reason for that
was the founding pastor.
So he founded that church in 1999,
of course, you know, preached the majority of the sermons,
so had a lot of influence in that way.
He's still there to this day,
and, you know, 25 whatever years later.
So just a huge influence,
and this for him personally,
like this was a huge value for him,
you know, relationships, relationships, real relationships.
So being on staff and such,
I had a chance to like, you know,
kind of like press in a little bit,
like because I was curious,
again with the eyes of an outsider,
like where is this, where is this coming from?
What's the, what's the thing here, you know?
And it was interesting as I talked with him,
it was really, it was a cultural diagnosis
that he could kind of just see
that things unraveling relationally,
you know, social bonds and ties
kind of fraying in the culture.
I mean, you think of it, for example,
even at the level of like,
not so much the nuclear family,
I think if anything,
we've kind of fallen back to that.
We're like, that's everything.
You know, so we're like,
you kind of batten down the hatches
with the nuclear family.
But if you think of like the extended family,
the way social ties have really frayed,
you know what I mean?
We don't tend to, I mean,
some people are still around like,
oh, their parents and grandparents
and great-grandparents
and everyone gets together like all the time
and there's tons of social support.
I mean, you can feel where kind of over,
you know, the last few like kind of decades
and really even centuries,
that sort of fraying as people move here and there
and, you know, it's kind of fraying.
And even the way it's,
he also kind of saw how
it was putting tremendous stress on marriages
as like that person
became your like everything.
You know what I mean?
Your like one key relationship
I can count on, hopefully.
You know, and that,
it's a lot of pressure to put on someone like,
yes, I'll be your everything.
Too much, you know, like too much.
And again, add to this,
he never mentioned this part,
but also I just know in his story,
he was a missionary for many years,
like through his 20s.
And I think something else he saw,
he saw I think the culture
with a little bit of an outsider's perspective.
Because if you've ever done, you know,
any sort of traveling or whatever,
like when you go into other cultures,
especially sort of non-Western cultures,
but really almost anywhere outside of America,
you immediately start to pick up on
like the pretty intense social bonds
cultures have, right?
That's like deeply, deeply communal.
It is not just about me as an individual
doing my thing.
You know, it's like, well, no, no, no.
This is about we.
This is about us.
This, you know, really intense,
yeah, kind of a togetherness.
And I see that even in our neighbor
lives to our left,
and they are Guatemalan.
I think immigrated through
in their like teen years.
And so now U.S. citizens,
but really, you know,
formative years in Guatemala.
And like you see the difference
like just in their culture
and in their household.
Like every weekend, there's like,
maybe not every,
but there's a lot of parties going on.
I'll put it that way.
And it's like everyone's about,
it's not like five vehicles show up,
you know, like, no, no, no, no.
It's like, come on.
I mean, even when we honestly barely knew them,
they're like, come on over.
Someone's having a birthday.
Like, come on everyone.
You know, that's just kind of the vibe,
you know, as a culture.
And again, contrast that with like
American, America suburban living.
You know, like, God forbid,
your neighbor parks in the garage.
You might never meet them.
You know what I mean?
Like, it's just pull in, pull out.
It's like, oh, bye.
And you kind of wave
and then they pull out their Tesla or whatever.
You know, like you never,
you never see these people.
And like, this is,
this is kind of where, you know,
the culture has gone.
In 2020, the Surgeon General
put out some statistics on like social connection.
And obviously it was the pandemic partly
that like spurred this on.
And some of these graphs you can see,
they kind of dip right there around 2020 pretty sharply.
And I know it's small.
The point is you don't have to,
oh, kind of read through some of these stats.
Really what I want you to notice
is just the general trend lines
in all but the first one.
And that's because it's social isolation.
So that's why it's up.
You know, it's the,
you're like, oh, that's good.
Oh, no, never mind.
Okay, social isolation is up.
Everything else, household family engagements
is just trending down.
Here's some of these statistics.
So people now spend an average of 24 hours per month,
more hours per month alone than they used to.
Oh, by the way, these are all since 2003.
That's kind of the trend.
Household family social engagement
has declined about five hours a month.
Companionship, which means sort of like shared leisure,
that's decreased by 14 hours per month.
Social engagements with friends
has decreased 20 hours per month since 2003.
Non-household family engagement
has decreased 6 1⁄2 hours per month.
Social engagement with others
decreased 10 hours per month,
and just kind of on and on and on.
Also, this will surprise no one.
People under age 35
are trending towards spending more and more time alone.
The number of young men right now
who spend more than 8 hours a day alone
has risen 20% since 2011.
More than 40% of young women today
report feeling lonely.
40%!
This is startling.
And what's interesting, too,
is these trends aren't like,
well, everything kicked off in 2003.
No, the trends have been going this way.
Even from the 1970s to the 1990s,
the frequency of folks
just hosting parties and get-togethers
and dinners and so on,
that declined from the 1970s to the 1990s
by 45% on average.
And then it declined again
from the early 2000s to today.
So it was another 32%.
So from the 1970s to today,
you have a 77% decrease
in folks just being like,
hey, come on over, let's get together,
whether a big party or just a small family.
It's just trending down.
So what's going on?
What's going on here?
What's up?
Well, kind of in keeping with the series,
I do think some of this is cultural.
Some of this is the kind of grand social experiment
that we've been undergoing.
So we have, obviously, this strong,
in the United States,
we have this strong kind of individualist streak in us.
The way we might sum it up is to say
the United States really was founded
on a view of the human being
as a kind of individual, self-sufficient,
rational, autonomous unit.
And we don't necessarily use that language all the time,
like, yes, I'm an American,
I'm a rational, autonomous unit.
I'm not saying we say that.
It's more of just how we,
almost kind of how our philosophy
and social contracts and such,
it's almost how it's...
I mean, you can even see it in the legal system very much.
People are very much treated as an individual.
Which, again, I think that's probably,
if there's an upside, that's it.
Where I personally don't want to be judged
for, like, the sins of my grandfather or something,
or, like, thrown in prison
because, well, your uncle was a political, you know,
such and such, and so we're getting...
Like, that's where you can see where the communal,
at the political level,
has its own kind of crazy and difficulties, you know.
I think the challenge is when it's not just the legal setting,
but it becomes a kind of cultural value,
or almost a hyper-individualism
that we just end up
kind of being very cut off from one another.
Yeah, now you combine that view of the human being
and the social settings it creates,
as we talked about earlier,
with the suburban homes,
all kind of not really facing one another,
you know, I mean, there's no common courtyards,
or, like, no, no, no,
everyone's kind of facing alone
and pulling in their garages,
and, you know, okay, so you get that,
and then you combine that
with the rise of technology, right?
The rise of, of course, television,
and then smartphones and social media,
and a dozen or so streaming services,
and, you know, what happens?
Well, you know, surprise, surprise,
people were kind of increasing,
you take that value with that technology,
and what you get is kind of,
well, people are just increasingly
spending more and more time alone, right?
As we kind of turn to the virtual,
to the technological,
to kind of fill our leisure time.
And my hunch is,
these trends are not going to, like,
reverse anytime soon.
I mean, maybe, I don't know,
maybe there'll be some massive cultural backlash,
and I think that'd be great.
But I don't know, I mean,
especially with, say, like, the rise of AI,
and kind of robotics,
and where all that's maybe going in the next ten years.
I don't know, like, what's going to happen
when, you know, our teenagers are like,
meet my robot girlfriend, you know, or whatever,
which I know sounds ridiculous,
but, I mean, if you keep up with some of that tech
that's coming, like, this is not,
like, it's going to be in our lifetime
that this is going to happen.
You know, so,
what is that, like,
what will that mean?
You know what I mean, like, where will this go?
In fact, I've used ChatGPT at times
for, like, mainly on the research,
not so much the writing.
Don't worry, I write my own sermons, but,
but for, like, research side.
And then recently it got memory,
right, where it basically remembers your previous,
you had to kind of update it every time.
Hey, this is my context, I'm a pastor at this place,
or I have this business, or I do that, you know, whatever.
Now it remembers, kind of,
who you are, it remembers all of your previous,
you know, kind of, entries, whatever.
So it said, hey, we got memory now,
so would you like,
hey, this is the prompt it said,
like, hey, we got memory now,
so ask ChatGPT the following,
describe me based on all our chats,
make it catchy.
And so this is what it said about me.
You're a contemplative pragmatist
with one foot in the pulpit
and the other in a philosophy seminar.
A preacher with a mystic's heart,
a biohacker's curiosity,
and a teacher's clarity.
You blend the spiritual with the cerebral,
quoting Exodus one minute and Zizek the next.
And somehow you make them shake hands.
You're deeply invested in transformation,
whether that's theological deconstruction,
stream entry, or just sleeping better,
so you can show up for your people
with wisdom and presence.
I feel so seen.
The robot loves me.
No one else gets me.
No one gets me except, I mean,
I'm joking, but you can see, right,
where this will go when you have this sort of
unendingly empathetic listening,
you know, I mean,
and combine that with no needs.
The robot doesn't need anything from you.
You know what I mean?
Like, just, I don't know exactly where it's going,
but I just think it's, yeah,
it's going to be problematic, right,
to put it mildly.
And because we're already kind of tempted
to kind of cocoon away
in our own little virtual worlds, aren't we?
Like, it's already kind of a temptation,
it's already a thing,
and then just where will it go
as that tech kind of increases?
Yeah, so what's the kind of Christian view of things?
You know, I think it starts with a kind of image of God, right?
God is, in God's very self,
is loving relationship,
Father, Son, Spirit.
And then you kind of build out from there,
and this is how I might sum it up.
Christian theology says,
I'm not an isolated individual
for whom technology can just satisfy all of my needs.
Rather, I am a self-in-loving community.
I put the dashes there
because I want that sense of connectedness.
Like, literally, it's not, I am a self,
and if I so choose and desire,
I may, I just may, or may not,
but I may choose to form certain voluntary associations
with others for a time.
No, no, no.
I am a self-in-loving community.
Like, this is who I am.
Like, no community, no self.
I've touched on this before,
but let me go a little bit deeper.
So, like, think of it like this.
Who would you be without the communities
that loved and raised and nurtured and mentored you?
Who would you be?
Like, nobody, right?
Like, this is how human beings are.
We're deeply formed.
Not even just deeply, but, like,
we are literally formed by the social settings,
the loving relationships
that matter so much to us in early life.
Right, in essence, you could say
we are not reptiles.
Reptiles, like, these are self-sufficient,
autonomous units.
Right, you think of, like, a baby crocodile.
Comes out of that, not that womb,
but the egg, I guess,
and it's just going.
It just heads out, and it's like,
sweet, living my life, you know,
doing its thing.
Just crocodiles, you know, just does its thing.
How does that go if you try that
with a human baby?
Not so well, right?
Like, you can't do that.
A human child, like, has to have
that kind of love, nurture, care.
And even if you were to have, like, a child
that you kind of, you know,
kept in a room alone,
but you fed it and watered it,
you know, so it technically lived.
Now, this is horrible.
Well, but these actually,
psychologists have studied folks
where this happened because of abuse.
Right, where they were kept alive,
but no love, no relationship.
What happens to them?
It's not good.
Right, yeah, like, they,
eventually they break down.
There's, why?
Why?
No community, no self.
I am who we are.
I'm formed.
Right, this is how God's kind of
wired us as mammals to,
to kind of need this,
to grow up into this.
There was a great,
one of the great psychological debates
that raged for years
was between the behaviorists
and the kind of social,
cognitive psychologists.
And one of the big questions was,
basically, it was about attachment.
How do these mammals,
how do they form attachments,
and why, and, you know, all that?
And what kind of put an end to the debate,
well, let me phrase it,
so, or set it up,
so the behaviorists said that,
you know, a mammal attaches to whoever,
well, they know where their bread is buttered,
so to speak, so they attach
to whoever gives them nutrients.
Often the mother, right?
And that's why they attach to those,
because of those nutrients.
The social and kind of cognitive
psychologists, they said,
like, no, no, no, there's,
there's more to it than that.
There's something about love
and relationship and such.
And there was the famous,
Harlow, the rhesus monkey experiments.
You've been through, like,
Psych 101, you've had,
this is, like, the famous,
yeah, I got an image.
So they, what they did was,
they put two,
they raised these little babies,
they never had any interaction.
They put two kind of mothers,
kind of in scare quotes, you know,
one, the wire mother,
you can see there,
and then another, kind of like,
had the wire kind of skeleton,
but then, you know,
little blanket and, like,
soft, fluffy mama.
Now, the trick was that the,
the wire mother is the one
who had the milk.
So that, so the, the,
kind of behaviorists said,
the monkey will attach
to the wire mother,
even though she's, like,
not super cuddly,
but she's got the nutrients.
And, and we'll kind of more
ignore the other one.
The social and cognitive
psychologists said, like,
no, no, no, they're,
they're going to attach
to the soft one, you know.
And, I mean,
you won't be surprised to hear
which one did the monkey
attach to.
I mean, you can kind of even
see it in that picture,
where this is what it would do.
It spent basically almost
all of its time
on the soft mama.
And then it would reach over
and get a little nutrients
and then come back.
It wanted almost nothing to do
with the wire mom,
even though that's where all
of its, you know,
food was coming from.
What, what's going on there?
Right, we, like, in essence,
um, love matters.
Attachment matters.
Relationship, emotions, feelings,
like, all of this matters
deeply to us.
This is who we are.
Companionship, comfort,
emotional connection.
I mean, in short, love,
it's just a, it's a huge deal
to us as human beings.
And, you know, at the end
of the day, like,
we can kind of critique
the mess out of Christianity,
you know, and I've done that
at times in sermons.
And certainly, if you know
about its history,
there's a lot we've gotten wrong
and all that.
However, if there's one, um,
kind of value,
one, uh, part of its theology
that, oh, it's so good
that it just gets
absolutely right,
it's the primacy of love.
Like, that's what Christianity
absolutely gets right.
Friendship, relationship,
community.
I mean, just think again,
John 12, 13, right?
I love this kind of
beautiful definition
of friendship.
Greater love has no one
than this,
than to lay down one's life
for one's friends.
I love that.
Like, who are your friends?
You just gotta ask yourself,
who are you laying down
your life for?
And if you kind of feel like,
I don't have any friends,
you know, it could be
that there's a lack of,
as we talked about
a few weeks ago
in our sermon on sex,
there's a lack there of agape,
sacrificial love, right?
Willing the best for the other.
Like, that's really
the heart of love.
It's the foundation
of all vibrant,
healthy relationship.
The poet William Blake said,
every kindness is a little death.
And what he meant was,
in essence, there's something
when we're giving to the other,
it's like there is
a sense of sacrifice.
There is a sense of,
it's not about me right now.
I'm not prioritizing
just me and my needs.
I'm there for you.
There's a beautiful definition
of kind of an agape,
a kind of sacrificial love.
And when I think of this verse,
you know, you could interpret it
in a kind of dramatic fashion.
You know, laying down
your life for your friends,
especially in light of,
it's Christ who's saying it,
so our minds immediately
go to the cross,
and it's sort of like the grand.
And you could interpret it
through a kind of grand gesture
interpretation, you know,
where it's sort of,
yes, I'm willing to lay down my life.
I would die for that person,
that relationship.
And that has its place, I agree.
That's a beautiful act of love.
But I want to interpret it
more through that,
the dailiness of living.
You know, isn't there something
about just showing up
for the people, the friends,
the community, the family
that we love?
And like, it's those little acts
of kindness, those little deaths,
those giving of ourselves
in that way.
Like, this is the very foundation
of love and relationship.
And it's important to name,
it's not that saying,
I don't matter,
or my needs don't matter.
Of course, this can,
agape can take its own,
sort of get weird and abusive,
and you know,
so I'm not saying do that.
But on the other hand,
we'd be kidding ourselves
if we didn't say,
there is something sacrificial,
you know, about love
and really what it means,
what it looks like.
If you've ever read
the pastoral letters
in the New Testament,
books like, you know,
Romans and Colossians
and Ephesians and all that,
they often end
with something like this.
This one's from Colossians,
from chapter four,
verses 10 through 15.
Paul writes,
My fellow prisoner Aristarchus
sends you his greetings,
as does Mark,
the cousin of Barnabas.
You've received instructions
about him.
If he comes to you,
welcome him.
Jesus, who is called Justice,
I guess they kind of
changed his name
because it was a little awkward
to keep calling him Jesus,
who is called Justice,
he also sends greetings.
These are the only Jews
among my co-workers
for the kingdom of God,
and they've proved
a comfort to me.
Epaphras, who is one of you
and a servant of Christ Jesus,
sends greetings.
He's always wrestling
in prayer for you,
that you may stand firm
in the will of God,
mature and fully assured.
I vouch for him
that he's working hard for you,
and for those at Laodicea
and Hierapolis.
Our dear friend Luke,
the doctor,
who wrote famously
the Gospel of Luke,
and Demas,
send greetings
and give my greetings
to the brothers and sisters
at Laodicea and to Nympha
and the church in her house.
What's the takeaway there?
Can you see that even
in its very earliest days,
like the church has never been
about celebrity pastors
or solo spiritual entrepreneurs.
Like, no, no, no.
The church is always rooted in,
yes, first the love of God
and Christ,
but then as that finds,
kind of it's planted
in like the soil of community.
It's a communal love.
It is about the people here
learning to love one another
in real and powerful ways.
But what I'm driving at, though,
is we are living in a culture
that is kind of pushing back on this.
That's sort of,
it's not like an active push.
It's more of a kind of passive,
like eroding,
you know, like the way maybe
a river kind of erodes the bank
of, you know, kind of its side.
It's just kind of over time,
and that's kind of how I see
secular culture.
It's just kind of eroding
relationships,
eroding social connections
and ultimately even at times
really impacting churches.
And I think it's really time
for us to, as best we can,
start to kind of push back on this.
To really start to invest,
not just in like simulated
online virtual living,
but like coming back,
coming back to flesh and blood
relationships.
Like people,
people that matter to us.
And then learning
to engage agape love
even then and there.
So let's start to kind of push back.
You know, let's begin
to rediscover how God
made us to be.
Let's be open to sacrificing
for one another
and allowing others
to sacrifice for us.
And of course here at the table
a lot of how we do this
is through our meetups.
If you're not part of one,
I encourage you to go online
or later we'll have the QR code
that has the link tree
that you can go find one there.
But those are beautiful
little expressions,
like little outposts of people.
Yeah, we're fumbling
and bumbling around.
I'm not trying to say like
these are perfect communities really.
No, no.
These are real people.
But there is something beautiful
as folks learn to relate
and sacrifice
and show up for one another.
So let's have these values
for us, you know,
communal, vulnerable.
Let's have these,
not just be like bullet points
on the website,
but something where
we're really living
as we press in
to the love of God
and what community
actually can mean
here in the 21st century.
So in the name of the Father,
the Son, and the Holy Spirit.
Amen.
So on the night
that Jesus was betrayed,
he had one final meal
with his disciples.
And at that meal,
he held up a loaf of bread
and he broke it
and he said,
take it and eat.
This is my body.
It's broken for you.
And he held up a cup of wine.
He said, take it and drink.
This is my blood.
It's shed for you.
Whenever you eat this bread,
whenever you drink this cup,
remember me.
So as we come forward today,
may it be a kind of
moment of solidarity,
may it be a moment
of community
as we partake
of the one body of Christ
and find ourselves
kind of enveloped
in his body.
And through that,
there's a sense of connectedness
and communion.
That's why it's called communion,
right?
Connection through that.
So we'll just go
row by row here,
starting at the front.
We'll form one line.
We practice an open table.
So if you're here tonight
and you want to participate,
feel free to do that
regardless of your exact,
you know, denomination
or theology or whatever.
The red is wine.
The white is grape juice.
And then finally,
you can just partake whenever
and however you'd like.
Some folks like to kneel
here at the front.
Some partake immediately.
You can just do that
however you'd like.
So this is the table,
not of the church,
but of the Lord.
And it's made ready
for those who love him
and for those who want
to love him more.
So come.
You who have much faith
and you who have little,
you who have been here often
and you who have not
been here long,
you who have tried to follow
and you who feel like you failed,
come.
Come because it's the Lord Jesus
himself who invites you
and it's his will
that those who want to meet him
should meet him here.
Come to the table.
Come.
Come..
All right, now let me send you into your week with this blessing.
You can hold out your hands in a posture of receiving or just open your heart to these
words.
You are a child of God.
You.
This is true on your best day, and it is true on your worst day.
So as you go into your week ahead with its yet to be determined highs and lows and everything
in between, go filled with the assurance that you are loved, that you are worthy, and that
you are accepted just as you are.
And go filled with God's Holy Spirit and the desire to extend these same gifts of grace
and unconditional love to everyone you come in contact with.
Be blessed, and we'll see you next Sunday.
I want a house with a crowded table, and a place by the fire for it to burn, and a place
by the fire for it to burn, and a place by the fire for it to burn.
I want a place for everyone.
Let us take upon the world while we're young and able, and bring us back together when
the day is done.
And bring us back together when the day is done.
When the day is done.